[Music]
Before a new vaccine
is ever given to people, a lot of
testing is done in a laboratory.
The next step is to test the vaccine in people in
clinical trials.
There are three
phases of clinical trials to make
sure a vaccine is safe and effective:
During Phase I clinical trials, small groups of people get the
vaccine. Phase I clinical trials are used to
determine if the vaccine is generally safe,
if it works, if there are
any serious side effects,
and what the best dose of the vaccine may be.
In Phase II clinical trials, scientists give the
vaccine to a larger group of people, including
people who have characteristics (such as age
and physical health) similar to those for whom the
new vaccine is intended. We use Phase II clinical
trials to study short-term side effects and how
people’s immune systems respond to the vaccine.
In Phase III clinical trials, scientists give the
vaccine to thousands of people to
determine if the vaccine is safe and effective. In
particular, we use Phase III trials to determine
how people who get the vaccine compare
with people who do not get the vaccine.
Once the U.S. Food and Drug Administration (FDA)
approves a vaccine for use, the FDA continues to
monitor the vaccine and its manufacturing
process to make sure that it remains safe.
The United States also has extensive
vaccine monitoring systems,
where patients, health care professionals, vaccine
companies, and health insurance companies report
side effects and other data to gather and
analyze information on the vaccine’s safety.